stellt euch das vor da stirbt angeblich
eine frau bei einem unfall und die leute
die ärzte nehmen diese frau mit
und auf einmal im fahrstuhl fängt diese
frau wieder anzuzapfen und lebt wieder
das ist wie im horrorfilm hey leute und
herzlich willkommen wieder zu einem
video luca sagt seine meinung und zwar
diesmal mit facetime unter anderem und
mithalten zieht gameplays wieder im
hintergrund
es haben sich ja auch übrigens erst mal
ein anderes thema und 20 einige gefragt
hey luca was es auf ein floß wie sie
bisher nicht mehr die lp ich habe mit
zornigen video gemacht was wir auf der
onyx kanal gemacht haben wir werden
wahrscheinlich noch mal alle zusammen
ein video machen deshalb heißt es
einfach nur die größte kommerzielle
scheiße dies gibt weltweit
und ja das ist erst mal meine meinung
dazu wir werden dazu eventuell mal
wieder zu machen zu den richtigen
gründen und es ist einfach lächerlich
aber egal
dazu kommen wir waren anders und zwar
geht es jetzt erst mal um andere themen
und zwar habe ich diesmal zwei themen
vorbereitet und was ich von euch jetzt
mal gern wissen würde findet ihr das gut
weil ich habe bisher so gemacht zum
beispiel zu miley cyrus dieser work
vorfall oder ich hatte noch ein anderes
thema wo ich auch was geredet hat zb
genau dieses minecraft buch zum beispiel
oder streams blog battle immer so
aktuelle themen in der youtube szene
aber auch in der news szene so ein
bisschen in der unterhaltungs den
celebrities so was alles da immer so ein
bisschen zu diskutieren was es da so
neues gibt meine meinung dazu zu hören
dauert dann nicht mal so lange laut
einer dem man nur ein paar minütchen und
nicht im wiso 15 minuten oder so
komplett auf das thema an das raten
vogel sehr süß eine spende ist nicht süß
ich bin männlich
nein komme nämlich sofort zum thema und
zwar dieses mal
ich habe hier einen bild artikeln offen
ich rolle manchmal einfach so durch ihr
bild ja kommen tötet mich nein es immer
ganz witzig was sie also an sachen
schreiben jedenfalls war dort eine
stelle ich das mal vor der wanne
hochzeit und eine frau also eine alte
frau ich glaube die warte moment ist
also ein bisschen durch die war 72
zusammen mit der tochter die 36 war
ein sechsjähriges enkelkind und noch
drei andere kinder waren in dem audi a4
kombi unterwegs aber irgendwie so eine
autobahn keine ahnung wo genau das war
das war bei hitze hohe keine ahnung
vielleicht kennt das einer von euch
schreibt man wenn ihr das kennt oder
wenn er in der nähe wohnt und wie gesagt
schreibt eure meinung zu den ganzen
vorfällen in die kommentare
erfahren da lang und machen einen unfall
und da kommt der polizei an und das sind
überall blut im schrei und was also eine
heftige horror story wirklichen und
wissen nicht was schönes da braucht man
jetzt noch nicht darüber lachen oder so
ist ich finde es einfach nur heftig was
danach passiert ist und zwar hat dieser
unfall dar und es ist halt die tochter
und der sechsjährige enkel der
totgeglaubten sind gestorben
und warum sage ich tot geglaubte genau
die 72 jährige oma da war tot geglaubtes
wurde dieses abc.de heißt es glaube ich
abc.de anwendet ich werde hier die ganze
zu geblendet dieses abc abc.de thema
brot schema wird angewandt und zwar ist
das so dass man erst mal reanimiert dann
versucht mit dem opfer zu leben zu reden
also erst zu reden dann reanimieren der
medikamente und so was alles sowie
verschiedene abläufe und alles nicht
funktioniert deswegen wurde die 72
jährige in einen sack getan was in
seiner tüte leckere keine ahnung gehalt
gleichen transportiert und wird dann
halt mitgenommen mit den anderen leichen
zu
das halt so akzeptieren und so was alles
jedenfalls als sie dann in einem
fahrstuhl waren wurde diese 72 jährige
frau auf einer lebendig bzw sie war die
ganze zeit lebendig die beiden
bewusstlos oder so und fing noch einmal
zum zappeln also das heißt sie hatte die
ganze zeit ein herzschlag
stellt euch das vor da stirbt angeblich
eine frau bei einem unfall und die leute
die ärzte nehmen diese frau mit
und auf einmal im fahrstuhl fängt diese
frau wieder anzuzapfen und lebt wieder
das ist wie im horrorfilm das ist so
heftig wenn ich diese art gewesen welche
ausgerastet ich hätte gedacht so wagt
die lebt kombi irgendwie sowas aber das
ist echt so heftig und ich verstehe
einfach nicht wie inkompetent diese
leute seien
lust haben gewusst seien haben sein
müssten ihr wisst was ich meine
die da diese frau mit diesem abc.de
stehen wir da versucht haben ihn wieder
ins leben zu holen
ich meine ich verstehe das nicht das
kann doch nicht wahr sein ich meine es
eine frau und die lebt aber die wird als
tot erkannt erklärt das ist doch heftig
alter sind so was verstehe ich echt
nicht wie inkompetent ärzte sein müssen
um so was nicht hinzukriegen also das
verstehe ich echt ich das war das wird
schon die story
ich wollte es heute teilt euch nur sagen
weil ich das einfach nur unerklärlich
finde wie doof manche leute sein können
da ist eine frau und ich mein ich will
jetzt nicht sagen dass sie so
unglaublich doof sind etwas habe ich
zwar gesagt aber das meine ich nicht so
ich möchte mir keine feinde machen dann
spaß sondern es ist halt einfach nur
unfassbar dass diese frau auf einmal
wieder lebt entweder dass es irgend ein
medizinisches wunder was unerklärlich
war oder einfach nur inkompetenz der
ärzte vor ort deswegen keine ahnung also
dass auf jeden fall schon mal heftig und
zweite sache tv duell von den
kanzlerkandidaten und zwar per
steinbrück und angela merkel kilometer
die waren da gegeneinander angetreten
ich hoffe jetzt alle geguckt das war
heute ist der wenn ich aufnehme es war
der dritte diese folge kommt am 4
dabei ist ihr habt es dass dir das
tv-duell war am 19
glaube ich da ich glaube beim ersten mal
war dass wenn ihr das nicht geguckt habt
ihr habt nichts verpasst es war kacke
das muss man so sagen ich fand's karte
es war kein offener schlagabtausch
es war immer so erst hat die geredet
dann hat hier wieder der steinbock
geredet dann wieder die merkel geredet
dass er alles irgendwie weil sie nicht
das ist also ich fand das jetzt nicht so
sondern heftige diskussion der einzige
gewinner in dieser show ist für mich
stefan raab weil stefan raab hat gezeigt
dass er politik sich sehr auskennt und
er hat halt wirklich so fragen gestellt
die sehr offensiv waren wurde an merkel
und steinbrück also gesagt haben ja auch
das parteiprogramm blabla und immer so
ein bisschen so rum geredet oder haben
dann halt mit einer anderen thema
angefangen dann wurden sie wieder
unterbrochen alle waren sehr steif auch
da jede klöppel der glaube ich auch
dabei weil diese chefredakteur bei rtl
chefredakteur ich weiß es gar nicht
diskutiert aber rtl war jedenfalls auch
dabei und angela merkel und peer
steinbrück waren beide im
ein bisschen defensiver wo man sagen
muss dass peer steinbrück ja der war
schon eher offensiv und angela merkel
hat mir so den die mutter komplexe
eingehen um so von wegen ich bin die in
die alte dame ich will euch beschützen
ich will hier dass die steuern gleich
bleiben und so was alles und peer
steinbrück spd war glaub ich steuern
sogar noch erhöhen damit deutschland
nicht mehr noch ein schulden fällt aber
das alles ganz andere themen das in der
wirtschaftskammer
jedenfalls war nicht das tv-duell
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen enttäuschend
ich will dich sagen auf welcher seite
ich bin julians blockieren video gemacht
penis politik sehr seriös auf jeden fall
wo er alle parteien schlecht geredet hat
außer die von ihm angestrebte partei und
das war auf jeden fall
nein also ich sage nicht welche partei
das ist aber ich will euch jetzt keine
partei sagen die in meiner meinung ich
schlag jetzt mit meinem handy in meiner
hand nein ich will euch keine partei
sagen die ihr wählen sollt ihr könnt
euch die parteiprogramme alle im
internet durch lesen ich verlinke euch
auch unten der seite dieses der wahlomat
da könnt ihr selber tests machen wenn
ihr über 18 seid und ich bitte euch
bitte bitte bitte bitte gehen wählen
weil das kann nicht wahr sein dass
weltkrieg herrscht verschuldung überall
und alle leute beschweren sich darüber
dass die politiker so scheiße ist aber
keiner geht wählen das verstehe ich
nicht wie will die wähler raten die
gehen so den bach runter ich verstehe
das einfach nicht alle beschweren sich
aber keiner erinnert was ist wenn ich 18
bin ich wert auf jeden fall wählen gehen
ich will ja irgendwie mitbestimmung naja
das war es erstmal wieder heute von luca
meinetwegen haben geknackt von lukas
news nein also hat keine serie
die sache ist jetzt erstmalig werde
eventuell diese serie fortsetzen denn
jeder lust an habe das könnt ihr mir
einfach in die kommentare schreiben
schreibt einfach mal
guy luca macht mehr von diesen news
celebrity haben sich wirklich so immer
wenn irgendwas wähle ich so mit der hand
ihr so weiter was sieht man nicht bei
dieser webcam
übrigens ist die webcam qualität dazu
ich kann mir den autofokus und so was
alles vorstellen allerdings na ja ich
werde auf jeden fall bei dieser webcam
belassen ich hoffe es stört euch nicht
dass die qualität so sieht man das ist
jetzt auch nicht weiter schlimm
natürlich war die canon qualität besser
aber da kann ich jetzt auch nichts mehr
machen und zwar die kerne nutze ich
jetzt hauptsächlich nur noch für
videoaufnahmen übrigens videoaufnahmen
es wird auf diesem kanal kein real live
videos mehr geben
es wird ich hab' ich habe ja gerade
schon ich glaube ich habe das gerade
schon hochgeladen
ich habe heute ja schon mal ein video
hochgeladen wo ich sage dass ich neuen
kanal gemacht habt ihr heißt er luca
filmt und so was alles und bla bla bla
bla bla
jedenfalls kommen da jetzt die ganzen
real live videos sowie zum beispiel
media markt hole oder blogs oder auch
sachen wie zum beispiel meine lieblinge
das ist eine neue serie meine
lieblingsfilme meine lieblingsspiele so
was alles das wird alles auf luca film
kommen der kanal verlinke ich warte
warte werden dass die anzeige ist
verlinkt ich euch den moment da dafür
lege ich euch den da könnt jetzt mal
drauf klicken
ich hoffe ich hab's nicht vergessen aber
das jedoch immer in der video
beschreibung wie könnt ihr einfach
abonnieren da mache ich mir live sachen
über media markt hole über das überdies
oder dies oder das so ganz ganz viele
verschiedene sachen halt also wenn ihr
mir von diesem celebrity krams
unterhaltungs news lukas meinung videos
sehen wollt was keinen richtigen namen
hat aber wo ich einfach sogar dem
quatsch die eventuell die weltgeschichte
interessieren dann schreibt einfach
einen kommentar mit jahr noch mehr davon
oder halt du behinderte [ __ ]
ich steckte eine eier oder so was halt
gibt den daumen hoch wenn es euch
gefallen hat wenn ihr auch meiner
meinung sagt und ganz wichtig schreibt
mir eure meinung dazu die kommentare
schreibt mir besonders eure meinung zum
tv duell in die kommentare
damit wieder halt mal so ein bisschen so
interagieren können wir wirklich sehr
oft auf kommentare ein und so was also
macht auch spaß dran
deswegen will ich da ich gerne eure
meinung hören und sonst geht auf luca
filmt und abonniert den channel oder
schreibt peter kommentare was ihr wollt
und besitz dann beim nächsten mal wieder